[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti quanto tempo
spendete ogni giorno su internet
bene quasi 5 miliardi di persone ogni
giorno nel mondo spendono almeno 5 ore
online
soltanto nel 2019
se consideriamo cumulativamente tutto il
tempo che abbiamo speso su internet
accumuliamo oltre un miliardo di anni
di questi ben 400 milioni soltanto sui
social media
in questo stesso istante mentre vi
racconto questi fatti ben mezzo milione
di tweet viene postato in ogni parte del
mondo e questo corrisponde grosso modo a
ogni utente ogni persona di verona che
twitta almeno due volte soltanto in
questo minuto e scambia concetti
opinioni e soprattutto idee come ci ha
raccontato leonardo di caprio un po di
tempo fa in film famoso un'idea è come
un virus può essere altamente contagiosa
si trasmette da una persona all'altra è
anche il più piccolo seme di un idea è
capace di crescere di germogliare in
maniera quasi incontrollabile e questa
non è soltanto una metafora in questa
visualizzazione di mostro dei dati reali
sono persone che twittano durante una
conferenza sul clima qualche anno fa e
ogni puntino in questa visualizzazione
corrisponde ad un messaggio ad un'idea
che viene postata sul clima e le
connessioni tra questi puntini
corrispondono a il botta e risposta
quindi idee che vengono date in risposta
ad altre idee quando le consideriamo
tutte insieme queste idee formano dei
veri e propri alberi di discussione una
rete che noi definiamo un albero d
idea ma allora viene da chiedersi qual è
la differenza se ce n'è qualcuna tra un
virus è un'idea c'è una grossa
differenza è la prima tra tutte è che
per fortuna non esiste un vaccino contro
le idee o un trattamento farmacologico
quindi qualche di qualche tipo
però ci sono anche delle delle
similitudini e per esempio
scusate per esempio come abbiamo
imparato in questi ultimi mesi un virus
ha bisogno molto spesso molti virus
hanno bisogno di un contatto fisico tra
le persone per trasmettersi da una
persona all'altra e ha bisogno di i
nostri dei nostri spostamenti per
muoversi da una parte all'altra di una
città o del del globo d'altro canto
un'idea può essere postata dal vostro
smartphone ha bisogno semplicemente di
una rete di comunicazione che metta in
contatto le persone viaggia su internet
e per questo motivo è decisamente più
veloce quindi da un lato abbiamo il
virus si muove su una rete di mobilità
invece l'idea si muove su una rete di
comunicazione e questo concetto e chiave
è importantissimo perché perché le reti
sono quello che io studio sono
un'astrazione matematica un concetto che
ci permette di aprire una porta e con
una lente sulla complessità dei sistemi
che ci circondano
probabilmente siete molto familiari con
il concetto di rete ogni giorno pensando
ai vostri contatti la vostra famiglia ai
vostri amici al lavoro qui vi mostro la
rete di facebook un equivalente digitale
dei nostri contatti sociali quei due
persone sono unite da una linea da una
connessione se hanno una relazione di
amicizia tra di loro
ed ecco che è proprio la struttura di
queste ready che quello che caratterizza
la diffusione dei virus e delle idee in
maniera che oggi non ho il tempo di
raccontarvi in dettaglio ma quando
un'idea è capace di viaggiare su una
rete ecco che possono succedere delle
cose veramente incredibili e questo è
l'esempio di greta samberg che tutti
conoscete la nota attivista per il clima
soltanto due anni fa veneta aveva
qualche centinaio di follower su twitter
oggi ne ha più di 4 milioni in meno di
due anni è stata capace di mobilitare
più di quattro opinioni di persone in
170 paesi
per supportare la sua causa per il
cambiamento climatico ed è questo quello
che voglio che vi ricordiate oggi la
prima la prima cosa che in un sistema
complesso delle piccole azioni dei
piccoli interventi possono portare delle
grandi conseguenze
noi non siamo abituati a questo modo di
pensare estremamente non lineare il
nostro modo di pensare più lineare
allora viene da chiedersi come si
configura tutto questo
queste reti queste informazioni che si
propagano questi virus che si propagano
sulle reti
quando andiamo a pensare a quello che
sta succedendo oggi ovvero nella patria
nella pandemia di coin 19 che come
sappiamo ha cambiato e non poco le
nostre abitudini e ha sconvolto le
nostre vite e quello che ci siamo
chiesti con il laboratorio di ricerca
che dirigo a trento alla fondazione
bruno kessler
noi abbiamo ascoltato i messaggi che
sono stati scambiati su twitter in tutto
il mondo a partire da metà gennaio e
abbiamo ricostruito questa rete di
interazioni tra gli utenti
chiaramente tutti i messaggi pubblici
non c'è violazione della privacy in
questo che cosa abbiamo abbiamo scoperto
che ad una prima analisi quello che
vediamo e che si formano dei gruppi in
questa rete e questi sono i pallini
colorati e questi gruppi riflettono
molto spesso quello che
sono informazioni del mondo fisico se
volete quindi la provenienza geografica
esempio l'italia o l'appartenenza certa
ideologia politica come per esempio i
repubblicani negli stati uniti ma siamo
andati più in dettaglio con con il mio
team e abbiamo analizzato i contenuti
che venivano scambiati in questi
messaggi
abbiamo realizzato quasi un miliardo di
tweet finora e di questi quasi mezzo
milione abbiamo l'informazione
geografica quindi siamo in grado di
assegnare un messaggio ad una location è
quello che abbiamo visto analizzando
anche io rl link che venivano inseriti
all'interno di questi messaggi e
analizzando le sorgenti a cui puntavano
le fonti quello che abbiamo trovato è
che quasi il 30 per cento delle notizie
che circolano in rete sono circolate in
rete in quel periodo provengono da fonti
che non possono essere ritenute
attendibili e perché questo è importante
questo importante perché come vi ho
detto prima un'idea si propaga da una
parte all'altra di una rete in cui vi
mostro un concetto che si è propagato
dal sud est asiatico fino all'altra
parte del mondo in un paio di settimane
e che riguarda una fake news ovvero
quella che per verificare se avete il
compito 19
basta che trattenete il respiro per
almeno 10 secondi ora questa è un'idea
che non fa del male
ok ma ce ne sono tante altre i colleghi
giornalisti e ricercatori ne hanno
identificate centinaia se non migliaia
in tutto il mondo e alcune di queste sì
che invece possono fare del male come
per esempio quella legata ai trattamenti
farmacologici
in risposta all'epidemia e in qualche
caso possono o hanno portato a delle ha
delle conseguenze molto molto serie ma
del resto l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità ci aveva avvisati
a febbraio ci aveva detto che con questa
epidemia loro si aspettavano un info
demi ha un nuovo fenomeno in realtà non
tanto nuovo era stato osservato
già in precedenza con con le boe la nel
in sostanza in questo questo fenomeno
corrisponde ad una sovrabbondanza di
informazioni che vengono postate in rete
che ci inondano e non ci permettono di
navigare bene di identificare quelle
fonti attendibili e quelle norme che ci
servirebbero per far fronte all'epidemia
in corso quindi ci confondono
ecco finora abbiamo parlato dei problemi
legati alle informazioni abbiamo
diagnosticato siamo in grado di
diagnosticare il il problema
la domanda è ci sono soluzioni per far
fronte a questo a questo problema
qualcuno ha suggerito che dobbiamo
regolare i social media come chiaramente
non possiamo pensare che qualcuno si
metta a controllare tutti i messaggi di
ciascuno di noi e quindi quello che
verrebbe fatto probabilmente e affidare
questa regolamentazione degli algoritmi
come gli algoritmi sappiamo che non sono
infallibili e quindi probabilmente
questa non è una soluzione efficiente
non è neanche una soluzione democratica
per tantissimi motivi
quello invece che dobbiamo cercare di
fare è trovare una simbiosi tra quelle
che sono le attività umane come la
comunicazione e questi algoritmi
io qui menzionano l'intelligenza
artificiale perché molto spesso questi
algoritmi si basano su un intelligenza
artificiale ma ci sono le grandi
organizzazioni internazionali come
l'unesco l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità che danno già delle linee guida
che vi permettono di far fronte a questo
a questo problema avendo in un certo
senso educati a leggere meglio le
notizie che vi arrivano e allora io qui
vi do qualche qualche anteprima sotto
forma di domanda
supponiamo che state leggendo una
notizia su twitter su facebook su
whatsapp perché magari arriva un link
tramite whatsapp fatevi queste domande
prima di tutto il titolo della notizia e
sensazionalistico ha un tono
sensazionalistico come seconda domanda
ponetevi la fonte da cui arriva questa
questa notizia può essere ritenuta
attendibile è una fonte istituzionale
una fonte governativa
il punto di vista di chi scrive
l'informazione come si sviluppa notizia
vi sembra molto di parte
mi sembra molto schierato sta provando a
convincere vi magari non portando
evidenze sperimentali o evidenze molto
molto chiare per supportare la propria
argomentazione e infine avete per caso
qualche dubbio sull'identità di chi vi
ha passato la notizia per esempio un
utente su twitter quindi magari pensate
che quella persona non è esattamente chi
dice di essere perché non c'è il nome
dell'utente perché non c'è la fotografia
ecco se la risposta da almeno una di
queste domande è sì allora da questo
momento in poi vi invito a pensare prima
di condividere
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]